did you stay out to watch your your
cowboys
i told you wait let me ask you this look
let me ask you a question
let's keep y'all with all mortals
backstory you grew up a steelers fan did
you there fellowship yeah cowboys did
you there no i didn't hate the cowboys
extension okay cool all right no no no i
was too young like when i was growing up
man look
i was following my big brother's lead
and so they had already
by the time i got to the steelers
i was doing that whole and people in
pittsburgh remember this you know they
won four championships in six years
right in the 70s everybody knows that
so
they were they kept they had this whole
campaign called one for the thumb
so by the time because they had their
four they wanted one more for the thumb
and so by the time i got to them
they had already won their four
yeah so i was a
one for the thumb
uh one for the thumb in 81 that was
another one the thumb is due in 82. they
had all these rhymes and
they did they had
and that you know you got the 83
84 85 and he said it just wasn't
happening
the thumb didn't happen so i didn't hate
the cowboys i you know who i hate it
just as a quick quick
quick diversion you know who i hated
as a steelers probably right probably
the raiders no
the steelers
the steelers i hated the steelers
because
i was at i was a draft nick even as a
kid
and i looked at their 1983 draft there
was a quarterback in the university of
pittsburgh
from pittsburgh
who wrote the steelers
and said draft me
please draft me
and they didn't
i feel like casey kasem and that
quarterback became
dan marino yeah so they didn't draft dan
marine i was just mad
so you resentful for several no the
reason i asked instead of dan marino
they had cliff scout anyway go ahead
yeah no reason i asked that
i'll get right to it because
you know we joked about uh you know we
we laughed to keep from crying we joked
about ezekiel elliot his fumbles last
night
the defense is on pace to be the worst
in nfl history to give up more points
than any team in nfl history by the end
of the year i think five teams have
given up more to their first um six
games whatever it is
so there's a lot to talk about but i
think
the the the situation in dallas is best
summarized i don't know if you saw this
photo going around but there's this fan
in the stands
with his face in his hands and his i'm
assuming it's his girlfriend maybe it's
his sister i don't know but the young
lady next to him is trying to comfort
him in the stands and that's basically
like you know what it's like to be a
cowboys fan right now in a nutshell
because even though you're two and four
in the worst division in the nfl and
we'll talk more about that in a minute
i mean
your offensive line is decimated you're
running back hey hold on to the ball
your
uh
your defenses is on pace to be all time
bad and come and find out today you have
players
anonymously telling the nfl network
these coaches have no idea what they're
doing they're unprepared they're
terrible at their jobs so getting back
to the steelers question i want to ask
you this because with the cowboys
typically typically you either love them
or hate them that's why they're probably
the biggest brand in the sport i want to
know if you derived any pleasure
from the cowboys pain that's what i was
getting at
no no no no no no no pleasure from it at
all i'm intrigued
like i'm just intrigued by the cowboys
that's why i told you
we started the show i said the cowboy is
going to be one of my beats
i'm going to be on the cowboys beat
because i'm just always fascinated by
what they do now this is before
i knew and i'm gonna say it already oh
six games in
am i being um hyperbolic i don't know
uh this is before i knew mike mccarthy
was the wrong choice
the coach said he's the wrong
guy for the job mike it's clear so
they were interesting before the season
started they were interesting before dak
prescott got hurt but now i look at him
mike you know what the intrigue is
if they are let's say they win their
division with a record of six and ten
which is very possible
six and ten five and eleven they win a
division
um
dak prescott
no we his contract status we know what
that is we talked about
uh bad organizations yesterday i don't
think the cowboys are a bad organization
but if i look at the top of that draft
i see a bunch of bad organizations there
you know dallas cowboys
you've got a bad record
you need a quarterback
you got jerry jones who's not going to
sit there passively do you make a move
not necessarily for trevor lawrence but
there are several quarterbacks they're
like four or five really good
quarterbacks right now we think so in
october
coming out of college football if you're
the cowboys do you make a move for one
of them i say you do
wait if if you are the cowboys
if you're the cowboy you try to get you
try to get up to get a quarterback why
would you do that yeah
because you're you're
because
dak prescott is hurt
and you and you don't know what the you
don't know
one how he's gonna recover from that
injury and two
does he want to be there do they want
him back i don't know i know what they
hey everybody said polite
i think they're being sincere you have
to say that but you can't but
it could be true but i also want to say
you have to say that and if you don't
say that you just wasn't you got bad
manners you just wasn't raised well
guy's hurt he's crying on tv everybody's
reaching out hey dad hey hang out dad
hey man much respect for you he has done
an incredible job also off the field of
really presenting himself
and and bringing up some issues that are
very important when we had one of our i
would say one of our best shows talking
about dak prescott and and um mental
illness and and uh just being up front
and talking about it and being open and
not hiding
i i got i had so much respect for doc
prescott but there's uncertainty at the
quarterback position and maybe
so maybe jerry jones would want to start
over at quarterback
all right so i'll answer that then i'll
go back to
yeah okay there's a lot to unpack from
what you just said you talk about
surprise tips there's a lot to unpack
there number one
we talked about the dolphins in their
seemingly endless search for and they
are apparent as a franchise quarterback
as a face of their franchise dan marino
okay
the cowboys had a similar search post
troy aikman until they lucked up and got
undrafted tony romo and then they got
even more good fortune
by stumbling upon that prescott in the
fourth round who as history may recall
as you may recall they didn't want dak
prescott okay that's not who they wanted
but they ended up taking him anyway and
the rest is history okay
they would be insane
just to to think
that okay
let's pass on that prescott and listen
it was a devastating injury a gruesome
injury there's no indication that he
won't fully recover from it they'd be
insane to pass on dak prescott for an
unproven prospect no matter no matter
how highly touted he may be
and and take a risk that trevor lawrence
or trey lands or justin fields will be
as good as dak prescott who side note
still leads the league in passing yards
which is probably more less a reflection
on how good he is even though he's good
the more reflection of the future their
defense is exactly a lot of empty how
far they've been buying nonetheless yeah
but nonetheless he is a franchise
quarterback if you how to empty yards
that dak was piling up but nonetheless
yeah but nonetheless
quarterback position or when you got one
that's getting older you draft an heir
apparent before you have to which brings
me to another point that i gotta
disagree with they're not a good
organization
what about the cowboys is not bad they
have a good they have they have a
successful brand
they are a popular team they have a
large national fan base but on the field
exactly what tells you that they're a
good organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports